I know you'd said in another video that
when you were teaching at UCLA that each
and I'm forgive me if you're on the
semester system or the quarter system
but okay each quarter or semester you
would see maybe two people in the class
that you really felt were like the gem
and the other the gems and the other
ones although with time and with proper
training they could become that I'm
wondering first of all those two people
as hypotheticals would they really know
could they see that they were different
from the other writers really really
okay how would they know and what would
they how could they see it and how could
you see it so I was talking about it
with a manager the other day and I'm
afraid I'm going to over answer your
question so I apologize ahead of time so
one of the key skill sets in addition to
creative integration is they build a
writing compelling conflict and
compelling conflict is what takes great
characters and great dialogue and just
makes it pop off the page it's just it's
hard to explain that you have a you
above this rule experience when you read
you can read you if you read some stuff
that's just bad and then you read some
stuff and it's got some great moments
and some great characters of dialogue
but it's nothing really happening then
you read some stuff and it's it's good
things are happening and it's
interesting but then you read something
it just pops off the page it just you
can tell I was a studio reader and I
could tell within one page if someone
knew what they were doing if it popped
off the page or not now if that one page
was great I don't know if they could
write out a whole script I have to keep
reading but if that one page didn't pop
I knew they couldn't and yeah if I had a
class of about 20 people they're usually
about two people and they're writing
just sort of popped off the page more
than others they didn't didn't know why
necessarily but everyone could tell and
I think they could tell they would often
not say anything it's like in a writing
group there's usually one person who's
writing just is better than everyone
else or in an MFA program it's just
maybe people don't know why but it does
what I've learned is it's because
they're writing and compelling conflict
and I find that about 5% of the writers
that come to work with me naturally do
that I don't have to teach them it just
has that popping off the page and about
5%
for to do that and the other 90% are
anywheres from they need some work today
they they suck at it they just suck at
it
but you can teach people how to do it so
a great example is Neil Simon the
playwright he has a book called rewrites
which is his autobiography he talks
about like year after year when he was a
younger man he'd write these plays and
he loved the characters and in every one
thought there was terribly funny but
they were just something missing they
just didn't hold together just wasn't
interesting enough and over time he's
like I know something's missing but I
don't know what it is and I know a lot
of writers who feel that way it's a
really terrible feeling he eventually
did the limping he never wanted to do is
he went to his older brother who was a
really successful writer and his older
brother read his stuff and said you're
not writing a compelling conflict and
Neil Simon's like what are you talking
about what is this and he said my older
brother taught me what it was and then
the light bulb went off and so then he
said I would just structure my
compelling conflict and then pour in all
the character in comedy and that's how
he did his career David Mamet and this
was on my website or you can look online
he did a memo about a decade ago or so
to the writers of the unit his TV show
and he basically said you will learn how
to write in compelling conflict or
you'll be in the blanking unemployment
line or the bread line and a lot of
f-bombs in this memo but he's basically
saying this is not a natural skill set
for most people you will learn to do
this or you will not survive and so I
didn't know it at the time and and to go
back to your question actually that the
for the truth of my experience was the
eighteen people who stuff wasn't popping
off the page they weren't I wasn't able
to get them there and so I like a lot of
teachers and I talk teachers at UCLA in
other film schools and they'll say this
privately I don't know they'll say this
publicly it's like yeah when you teach a
class you're teaching for that one or
two person or people who have what it
takes the rest don't but look they have
a dream support them be encouraging
don't tell them that they don't have
what it takes
they'll figure it out and then when they
figure it out
they will give up this dream and they'll
find the dream that they have the talent
for because not everyone could be a real
clash f91 could be a professional
athlete and so we teach for that one or
two that have what it takes and for the
rest we don't tell them that they don't
have what it takes we could be wrong but
they'll figure it out and that's a real
fixed mindset way of approaching this
and one of the books that changed my
life as a teacher is mindset by Carol
Dweck I make all my students read it's
the only thing I make them read she
talks about the fixed mindset in the
growth mindset and the growth mindset is
okay these two people who there says
popping off the page why what skills
what talent today how the other people
don't have and the growth mindset says
talent is repeatable skillsets and maybe
you're born with them
maybe you develop them through nurture
and childhood or maybe you learn them as
an adult it doesn't matter how you
acquire them it's just a skill set
that's repeatable as opposed to luck so
repeatable skill set is you know you
learn how to drive a car you can drive
you now you can always drive a car right
a bike and so they have the people that
pop off the page they have certain skill
sets certain tools the other people
don't you can figure out what those are
compelling conflict and then you can
start how to teach compelling conflict
then you can teach those skill sets to
other people and they can learn that
talent and with so I I have I had a
writer that kind thing to me is named
Gary and he had a manager and he was
always taking meetings but he could
never sell anything he could never get
hired he felt like he was that close to
a career for five years and at some
point you're like okay this something's
not here something's not working so he
came to me deeply into it a writer that
he wrote the most amazing characters and
dialogue I didn't all I taught him on
that front was don't change what you're
doing
he does like you're amazing just keep
doing that
don't let anyone interfere with that but
on the conceptual side you've got some
real weaknesses and him specifically was
escalations how to keep making things
strong like keep making things worse and
worse than an organic way that was his
so he was an easy case in that he had
everything but one skill set he was
really missing one skill set so I gave
him those training exercises and then
unbeknownst to me when I was done with
that class he spent the next three
months doing those training exercises
everyday for four hours I didn't know
that that's a growth mindset guy that's
a guy who's like I want to become an
expert at this skill set that I
naturally am terrible at and at the end
of those three months he was as good at
that as a natural conceptual writer is
good at that he was just as good at that
as anyone he now has a movie kinda that
I think it's released in the fall
starting um what's her name um anyway
not Reese Witherspoon but someone like
anyway he has a movie that that come out
he has a Missy agents he sold two TV
pilots and he had everything but that
one skill set now at the same time I've
worked with writers who are graded
escalations and great at big concepts
but their character is in dialogue it's
just like these are puppets and through
the intuitive training they could come
out the other end where their characters
and dialogue are just as good as these
people who are naturally great so the
key is you have natural talents and then
there's talent that you don't have oh
you're not that strong yet if you train
the right way you can if you're willing
to put the time and effort in the right
way you can end up being just as
talented as someone who's naturally that
way and that's the growth mindset so for
years I honestly and I'm embarrassed to
say this but for years I would teach a
class and I come home and I see how it
goes I go these two people I think could
have careers the rest of them not so
much and over time usually those two
people would go on to have careers and
none of the others and I'm like well I
teach for those two people I encourage
everyone else because you never know but
probably going to find out they don't
have what it takes when I change this
approach and it took a long time and all
effort I remember I had a class where
there it was only ten people there was
one person who you could tell how did it
take the other nine No
and within four years one of those nine
people dropped out because of long story
so that left eight and of that eight six
of them went on to got careers and I
wasn't a smarter or more dynamic or I
wasn't a better teacher than prior I
just had a different teaching approach
and it was the approach that was
radically different until creative
integration skill set same approach so
it took me years and a lot of help from
other people I didn't just invent all
this myself but that's the really cool
thing about talent and is that it's
repeatable skillsets and you can learn
these skill sets and you can develop
them if you know how to train yourself
and you want to put the time and energy
into
you